ethics guidance for research involving
human participants has been developed
and disseminated by numerous
organizations and agencies at
international
regional and national levels over the
past fifty years
adherence to these guidelines helps to
promote the ethical conduct of research
and enhances and protects the rights and
well-being of research participants and
communities
a core component of all contemporary
research ethics guidelines
is that research should be subject to
prior ethical review by a competent
institutional review board or irb
such review is intended to ensure that
the ethical principles and practices put
forward in the guidelines will be
followed in the proposed research
irbs may review different types of
research studies including
but not limited to the following
clinical trials
epidemiological research social science
research
research on medical records or other
personal information
research on stored samples health
systems research
and implementation research irb should
be familiar with the different
methodologies and ethical considerations
that apply to each type of proposed
research they review
the irb is constituted according to a
charter or other
document that establishes the manner in
which members and the chair will be
appointed
the appointing entity ensures that the
irb has a multi-disciplinary and
multi-sectoral membership
that its composition is gender balanced
that it reflects the social and cultural
diversity of the communities from which
research participants are most likely to
be drawn
and that it includes individuals with
backgrounds relevant to the areas of
research the committee is most likely to
review
the entity establishing the irb takes
the following factors into consideration
when appointing members
individuals with scientific expertise
including expertise in behavioral or
social sciences
health care providers and members who
have expertise in legal matters or
ethics lay people and other members
whose primary background is not in
health research with human participants
their primary role is to share their
insights about the communities from
which participants are likely to be
drawn lay people are appointed to
sufficient numbers to ensure that they
feel comfortable voicing their views
in order to enhance independence board
membership also includes members
who are not affiliated with
organizations that sponsor fund
or conduct research reviewed by the irb
irb need to ensure that the committees
are large enough to ensure that multiple
perspectives are brought into the
discussion
to this end quorum requirements provide
that at least five people
including at least one lane member and
one non-affiliated member
are present to make decisions about the
proposed research
the entity establishing the irb supports
it with adequate resources
including staffing facilities and
financial resources to allow the irb to
effectively carry out its
responsibilities
as an integral part of a health research
institution or health system an irb
receives support staff adequate in
number
and training to enable the irb to carry
out its technical
and administrative responsibilities
adequate resources for the staff to
fulfill its assigned functions
including office space and equipment and
supplies such as computers stationary
telephones photocopying machines
shredding machine and etc
to conduct administrative business to
store committee files
and to keep documents secure and
confidential
access to appropriate space for the
committee to meet an adequate means for
members to communicate as needed between
meetings
adequate financial resources to permit
the committee to produce high quality
work
and resources necessary to compensate
irb members
unless they are already being
compensated for their time and effort on
the irb through other means
policies governing the irb include
mechanisms to ensure independence of the
irb's operations
in order to protect decision making from
influence by any individual or entity
that sponsors
conducts or hosts the research it
reviews
such policies provide at a minimum that
irb members
including the chair remove themselves
from the review of any research in which
they are close family members have a
conflicting interest
to ensure that the irb cannot be
pressured to approve or disapprove
particular protocols
the charter bylaws policies or
procedural rules of the irb
provide that the irb's membership
includes at least one person with no
connection to the organization that
sponsors
or conducts the research under review
researchers
sponsors and funders may attend an irb
needing to answer questions about their
research protocols and associated
documents
but they are not present when the irb
reaches decisions about their proposed
research
senior decision makers of the entity
creating the irb
or of any organization that sponsors or
conducts the research reviewed by the
irb
such as the director of an institution
or his or her agent
do not serve as members of the irb or
its chair
and the entity that establishes the irb
ensures that irb
members are protected from retaliation
based on positions taken with respect to
irb related matters or review of
research projects
training on the ethical aspects of
health related research with human
participants
how ethical considerations apply to
different types of research
and how the irb conducts its review of
research is provided to irb
members when they join the committee and
periodically during their committee
service
the training provided to irb members
either directly by the appointing entity
or through cooperative arrangements with
other irbs or organizations that provide
education on research ethics
focuses on the role and responsibilities
of the irb
and its role this save as other relevant
entities according to relevant
international guidelines
such as international council on
harmonization good clinical practice
or ich gcp national laws and
institutional policies
the full range of ethical considerations
relevant to research with human
participants
the application of such ethical
considerations to different types of
research
basic aspects of research methodology
and design for members who lack such
background
the impact of different scientific
designs and objectives on the ethics of
a research study
and the various approaches for
recognizing and resolving the tensions
that can arise among different ethical
considerations
and modes of ethical reasoning when
training is supported by research
sponsors
mechanisms are in place to ensure that
the sponsor has no control
direct or indirect over the content of
the training
mechanisms exist to make irb operations
transparent
accountable consistent and of high
quality
the entity establishing the irb employs
reliable means to evaluate whether the
staff and members of the irb
routinely follow the irb's policies
rules and written procedures
with special attention to whether the
ethical considerations articulated in
international guidelines and national
standards
are being considered and applied
consistently and coherently
such evaluations are conducted by
knowledgeable and unbiased people at
regular
predefined intervals using a predefined
format
the results of the evaluation are of a
type that can aid the irb in reviewing
its practice
and appraising performance rather than
apportioning blame
while also assuring the public that
research is being reviewed according to
established standards
researchers research participants and
other interested parties have a means of
lodging complaints about the irb such
complaints should be reviewed by an
entity other than the irb
itself and appropriate follow-up actions
should be taken
researchers also have a means of
discussing concerns with irb members
both on general matters and in response
to irb decisions on particular research
studies
irb decisions excluding confidential
information
are made publicly available through
mechanisms such as clinical trial
registries
websites newsletters and bulletin boards
the primary task of an irb is the
ethical review of research protocols
and their supporting documents approval
or disapproval is based on the ethical
acceptability of the research
including scientific design and conduct
of the study
research is ethically acceptable only if
it relies on valid scientific methods
irbs should have documentation from a
prior scientific review
or should themselves determine that the
research methods are scientifically
sound
and should examine the ethical
implications of the chosen research
design or strategy
unless already determined by a prior
scientific review
irb should also assess how the study
will be conducted
the qualifications of the researchers
the adequacy of provisions made for
monitoring and auditing
as well as the adequacy of the study
site such as the availability of
qualified staff and appropriate
infrastructures
risks and potential benefits in
ethically acceptable research
risks have been minimized both by
preventing potential harms and
minimizing their negative impacts
should they occur and are reasonable in
relation to the potential benefits of
the study
irb members should be aware that risks
may occur in different dimensions
such as physical social financial or
psychological
and harm may occur either at an
individual level or at the family or
population level
selection of study population and
recruitment of research participants
ethically acceptable research ensures
that no group or class of persons bears
more than its fair share of the burdens
of participation in research
similarly no group should be deprived of
its fair share of the benefits of
research
these benefits include the direct
benefits of participation
as well as the new knowledge that the
research is designed to yield
thus one question for research ethics
review to consider is whether the
population that will bear the risks of
participating in the research is likely
to benefit from the knowledge derived
from the research
in addition ethically acceptable
research includes recruitment strategies
that are balanced and objectively
describe the purpose of the research
the risks and potential benefits of
participating in the research
and other relevant details inducements
financial benefits and financial costs
it is considered ethically acceptable
and appropriate to reimburse individuals
for any costs associated with
participation in research
including transportation child care or
lost wages
many irbs also believe that it is
ethically acceptable to compensate
participants for their time
however payments should not be so large
or free medical care or other forms of
compensation so extensive
as to induce prospective participants to
consent to participate in the research
against their better judgment or to
compromise their understanding of the
research
protection of research participants
privacy and confidentiality
invasions of privacy and breaches of
confidentiality are disrespectful to
participants
and can lead to feelings of loss of
control or embarrassment
as well as tangible harms such as social
stigma rejection by families or
communities
or lost opportunities such as employment
or housing
irb should therefore examine the
precautions taken to safeguard
participants privacy and confidentiality
informed consent process the ethical
foundation of informed consent is the
principle of respect for persons
competent individuals are entitled to
choose freely whether to participate in
research
and to make decisions based on an
adequate understanding of what the
research entails
decisions for children or adults who
lack the mental capacity
to provide informed consent should be
made by an authorized surrogate decision
maker
irb should examine the process through
which informed consent will occur
as well as the information that will be
provided
irbs may waive the requirement of
informed consent only when doing so is
consistent with international guidelines
and national standards
while informed consent to research is
important the fact that a participant or
surrogate may be willing to consent to
research does not
in itself mean that the research is
ethically acceptable
and finally community considerations
research has impacts not only on the
individuals who participate
but also on the communities where the
research occurs and or to whom
findings can be linked duties to respect
and protect communities require
examining by the irb
and as far as possible are aimed at
minimizing any negative effects on
communities such as stigma or draining
of local capacity and
promoting as relevant positive effects
on communities
including those related to health
effects or capacity development
researchers should actively engage with
communities in decision making about the
design and conduct of research
including the informed consent process
while being sensitive to and respecting
the community's cultural
traditional and religious practices
decisions on research protocols
designated for review by the convened
irb
are based on a thorough and inclusive
process of discussion
and deliberation protocols involving no
more than minimal risk and burden to
research participants may be reviewed on
an expedited basis by one or more
members
rather than the full committee if the
irb has established written procedures
permitting such a procedure
during meetings of the irb members
engage in discussions to elicit all
concerns and opinions related to the
protocols
and the associated documents under
consideration
the irb's rules ensure that the
discussions are respectful of all
opinions
and allow for varied beliefs to be aired
decisions are made only by those who
were present during the entire
discussion the chair is responsible for
the decision-making process
researchers funders or others directly
associated with the protocol in question
are not present during committee
deliberations
irb members recognize the limitations of
their knowledge and can seek external
input when necessary
decisions are arrived at through either
a vote or consensus
consensus does not require that all irb
members support the decision
but that all members consider the
decision at least acceptable and no
member considers the decision
unacceptable